[Music]
I have a very Sleazy and oily Mexican
here oh wow
wow he knows what he's doing holy [__]
holy [__]
yeah I mean it gets it gets way worse
what what's great about this is that bit
right there I know is just making the
rounds as a bit yeah it's like my white
girlfriend bringing me home to her
family
suit I will fill him up as well two
buttons real bone buttons a la peaky
blinders a peak lapel with my dot dot
dot dot hand needle and thread pick
stitching Buckhead a brush pocket with a
curve and can I kiss you yes what can I
brush pocket with a curve
can I kiss you yeah
check out the pocket flap slightly
undersized fully pick stitched and fully
flat the boy is definitely gift wrapped
in my 4D fit I love the double vents
because when you pull it up you can see
his ass straight away let me unwrap him
let me unwrap him for you show you all
the naughty stuff that's going on inside
his mind now that we have the jacket off
we can have a closer look at his ass you
like me to feel it or slap it
slap it you've heard it Mexicans like it
slap
Los Mexicanos are you happy yes very
happy thank you man that guy's voice is
deep as hell that was a turn right there
was that jazz very happy
was that not the most important slap it
slap it
is that one of the most insane video I
can't tell if that guy's in on it I
don't think he was I think they [__]
after
before and after they want each other
right there can I
yes
[Laughter]
a boy is definitely gifted the boy is
definitely gift wrapped
yeah so this guy does this like every
video is like this yeah the only other
will be like a 20 year old like dude
like young Chinese boys flock to me yes
yeah but then if you go back if you
scroll back like two months ago he
doesn't do that and his his like Cadence
was totally different so he clearly was
like oh being being racist being racist
and like assaulting people works for
sales yeah he's like well the business
was good and then I turned racist and
business was boom yeah exactly hey
aren't you that racist guy from Tech
talk make me a [__] the most racist
suits what do you think he would say
about you if you went in
I've got this mixed race Trader
I've got this mixed product of race
trading we don't even know whose race
betrayed who
but he's disgusting he's a mutt and I
want to put him in a bag and keep him
for myself the boy is wrapped
it's rubbing the top of my head you only
get oils like this on foreigns
the foreigns they sweat they're used to
different environments all the people he
films like this they all have this like
sort of smile on them or I think he just
tells them like smile yeah and
like I don't think he I don't think
they're in on it they're all kind of
like what the [__] is this guy saying
what the [__] or does he hook up with
them on grinder first and then he goes
you want to make a quick video yeah
maybe that's what they're like yeah sure
he's like I'll pay you and it's Gonna Go
My Tick Tock account they go yeah sure
whatever damn he just face pawned that
guy what the hell
[__] wet for this
Dwight
you say tight look at tight tight tight
two buttons
for this tight white Italian look at
look at the way he stares at him after
he does that look at that she's like
just take me now he's smitten yeah he
kind of is this guy's into it a lot of
them a lot of them aren't that haircut
is crazy okay we get that frame hold on
hold on hold on hold on hold on the
[__] coconut
haircut
dude he looks like the top of a [__]
like pina colada stand
look at tight tight tight two button
you're about to jerk him off right now
mazoni horn buttons a narrow Peak lapel
with my dot dot dot dot hand needle and
thread pick switching accent color in
the buttonhole bucket of breast pocket
with a curve and kick the peak of my
pocket square as we come down you can
see he is just stuck in my signature
details undecised pocket flaps slanted
Pockets pick stitch Pockets fully lined
Pockets overlapping buttons on the cuff
check out the accent color in my fully
functional couples he is gift wrapped
look at this gift wrap in my 4D fit
check out the pop vent you know he's
Italian's ass is showing oh my goodness
let me
look at that [__] look at that smile
he's like yep
I'm about to back it up on him
oh this little little boy show you
what's going on inside absolutely
glorious and you already saw his ass but
we gotta look at it one more time
gift wrapped in my 4D fit Italian boy
are you happy I am you're the best man
thank you oh oh he snug a kiss
yeah yeah how does he talk about this
woman that one this boy is just hold up
Mom whoa I'm blind out my left eye yeah
straight up blind
there you go yeah for real
I thought that was someone's mother
listen to what he says I feel so bad
yeah I feel oh so you've seen this guy
this boy is just dripping why dude why
does he have him in [__] like level
three armor yeah I know that's like not
a good suit no constantly dripping in
sweat so I have to cover him up in a ton
of clothing to hide and absorb the sweat
the missing arm is called air
conditioning let me unravel him and show
you just how sweaty he is inside we
shall take the first layer of cashmere
off and show you a gorgeous suit that
matches his very red hair and he is just
sweating notice one less arm here for
air conditioning because he is just
sweating let me Strip This poorly
redhead down and show you now two
missing arms because he is just sweating
oh my goodness he is sweating I have
never seen someone as drenched as this
ever and now voila now you have to see
why I have to cover him up because he is
just sweating are you happy always thank
you like are the internet
yeah
yeah this is a poor guy yeah that that
one wasn't really fun I know that was a
poor guy you know yeah
that wasn't fun become a portly redhead
portly redhead yeah
poor guy gorgeous Russian girls are just
lining up for me look you could I mean
we we know what his type is but look at
him trying to force the compliment for a
woman yeah yeah
gorgeous Russian
girls
he's sick saying it man
yeah
you gotta you gotta you gotta hanker in
to get a suit all of a sudden
yeah actually I do
some Canadian white boy dumb Canadian
white boys line up for me